i've talked many times in this channel
about my infatuation with galileo
galilei the father of modern science he
more than any other individual applied
the tools of the scientific method to
uncover new truths using evidence to
back hypotheses that he himself and
others had conjectured
with a tiny tube no longer than his own
arm he figuratively displaced the earth
from the position of centrality that it
had enjoyed for millennia before he
turned the telescope to the heavens this
like archimedes gave us a lever big
enough to move the world and yet in some
ways his most magnificent contribution
was what was called the assayer or ill
sagittarii in this wonderful book
galileo laid out arguments for and
against the existence of comets being
phenomena in our atmosphere or in the
heavens itself it's a wonderful book but
i thought it would be wise to discuss
this project as it relates to my channel
and what i hope to do on this channel to
be an assayer of a certain type what is
an asshair
an assayer is a individual who has a
piece of stone and with this piece of
stone he scrapes something that is
punitively ascribed to be gold perhaps
by the king the king comes to the
assaira and says test this piece of gold
which i think is gold and tell me if i
got a good deal or not the assailer
takes the piece of gold and test it by
scraping and if it rubs off in just the
right way the assailer can confirm to
the king that this is correct and this
piece of gold truly is gold or if it's a
worthless rock which case he better look
out because the king may take it out on
the messenger but in truth an assayer
takes something that has no value pretty
much just the rock and uses it to define
and determine something of perhaps very
very enormous value a piece of gold or
to determine if it's worthless
what i'd like to do in this channel is
use the power of experimental reasoning
of observation and of evidence-based
thinking to assay to test theories of
everything that have come across all of
our collective consciousness on this
channel and in other places around the
web
what i would like to do is assay and
test the veracity of different models of
cosmogenesis the origin of the universe
origins of structure of space-time and
matter and in so doing i want to take
you along for a ride so i call this
project the assayer project doing what
galileo did 400 years ago not as good as
him but i'll do my best to use the tools
and technology of modern experimental
physics and astronomy to test whether or
not these new theories these new models
these new claims are truly worthy of our
attention so come along with me on what
i call this magical ride taking back to
what el maestro galileo did 400 years
ago in a magnificent book called the
sagittarii the assayer